in this video we'll talk about the
glycogen storage disorder
glycogen storage disorder occurs due to
defect in the enzymes which are
associated with the glycogen metabolism
there are at least 13 of these glycogen
storage disorder
all these 13 glycogen storage disorders
are named as like type 0
type 1 type 1b type 3 etc before we
learn about these disease in bit more
details we should understand the
biochemistry and the pathology of this
particular disease
now in glycogen storage disorder
all the enzymes which are associated
with glycogen metabolism has some kind
of problems
this is the glycogen metabolism pathway
and generally the enzymes are defective
since these enzymes are abundant in
muscle and liver
so the most affected organs in these
kind of disorder is the liver and the
muscle
now let's talk about the causes of gsd
or glycogen storage disorder
so there are several enzymes which
augment the synthesis of glycogen or
breakdown of glycogen so the breakdown
of glycogen is catalyzed by enzymes like
debranching enzyme glycogen
phosphorylase phosphoglucomutase
glucose 6 phosphatase and in these
glycogen storage disorder these enzymes
are defective for example glucose
6-phosphatase is defective in von garrix
disease
then in macarthur and hearth's disease
glycogen phosphorylase is defective
de-branching enzyme is defective in
cory's disease
anyway we can broadly understand the
overall metabolism of glycogen is messed
up so in order to understand the disease
pathology we have to understand the
biochemistry of glycogen metabolism
first
glycogen is a fixed deposit of glucose
like you keep fix depositor for your
money in the bank
in our body glucose is stored as
glycogen
so glucose gets converted to glycogen by
a process known as glycogenesis
and
whenever it is required glycogen gets
broken down to produce glucose and this
is known as glycogenolysis
processes like glycogenolysis is super
important in the context of starving
fasting or let's say when our body needs
a huge amount of
energy in that case glycogen which is
stored in liver or muscle would be
broken down and that glycogen
can produce glucose which would be
fueling our brain or other organs to
function
now glycogen metabolism has two part
broadly making of the glycogen and
breaking of the glycogen the glycogen
synthesis is known as glycogenesis
so glucose is the raw material from
where the glycogen is synthesized
so from glucose there would be
conversion into glucose 6-phosphate with
the help of the enzyme hexokinase and
these glucose 6-phosphate can ultimately
generate pyruvate and in this process
atp would be generated but imagine a
situation when you have a lot and lot of
atp
in that case your body can actually use
these glucose 6-phosphate to produce
glycogen so glucose thick phosphate in
that condition would be converted into
glucose one phosphate which would be
further converted into udp glucose and
incorporated into a glycogen chain so
this is how glycogen synthesis takes
place
so overall this process is known as
glycogenesis
and glycogenesis occurs when glucose
level in our body is high like when we
are well fed and had a
nice sugary meal
so glycogen
is generally stored in muscle or in the
liver majorly
and there are particular protein known
as glycogen in which helps in the
polymerization of this glycogen
anyway
so there are hormonal regulation of
glycogen synthesis for example glycogen
synthesis is the key enzyme in this
process
now there are several kinase and
phosphatase enzymes can act like switch
so in a phosphorylated version glycogen
synthesis is inactive
in a d phosphorylated state it is active
so kinase enzyme would inactive the
process and phosphatase enzyme would
active the process
so insulin augments the phosphatase
enzyme thereby activating
glycogen production
whereas glucagon or epinephrine inhibits
this process glucagon activates kinase
moreover and thereby preventing
the glycogen synthesis and increase
glucose levels
anyway there are complex hormonal
regulation now glycogen breakdown
happens via stepwise manner so in the
glycogen breakdown process
there would be a glucose generation in
muscle and liver which could be used for
a generation of
atp ultimately it would be broken down
into glucose 6-phosphate that broken
down glucose 6-phosphate can be
channeled into glycolysis pathway to
generate atp whenever it is necessary
and this process is known as
glycogenolysis in starved state or in
conditions of high energy demand this is
predominant process now glycogen
phosphorylase was would kind of like
chop off uh specific residues from the
sides of these glycogen chain
and whenever it encounters a branch
point then it is replaced with a
de-branching enzyme and the d branching
enzyme cleave of the branch point and
specially it leaves off that alpha 1 6
glycosidic linkage and then de-branching
enzyme disengage further glycogen
phosphorylase can chop off
linear branches
ultimately glucose 1-phosphate is
released due to this de-branching
procedure anyway phosphoglucomutase then
converts this glucose one phosphate in a
sequential fashion to glucose 6
phosphate now glucose 6 phosphate is now
broken down into glucose by the enzyme
called glucose 6 phosphatase
now let's talk about the classification
of glycogen storage disorder glycogen
storage disorder can be classified into
several groups like type 0 or lewis
disease
type 1 vongeric disease
type 1b
type 2 which is known as pompeo's
disease type 3 forbes and corey disease
type 4
anderson's disease type 5 type 6 and
many other types as well
now
beyond all these classifications and
everything what we should see and notice
that in all these cases the organs which
are highly affected are liver and muscle
and that's pretty much expected because
glycogen metabolism is happening in the
liver and my muscles predominantly
that's why these are the organs which
would which are expected to be affected
anyway this is the overall glycogen
synthesis pathway and we are going to
talk about few selected glycogen storage
disorders just to get us some just to
get some idea that what really happens
under these kind of diseases first we
are going to talk about the von garrick
disease which occurs due to a defect in
glucose 6 phosphatase enzyme
then we'll talk about mcardle and
hearth's disease which happens due to
the problem in glycogen phosphorylase
enzyme lastly we'll talk about corey's
disease which is a problem due to the
de-branching enzyme
now let's talk about the von gerick's
disease at the first place this is known
as type 1 glycogen storage disorder in
this case glucose 6-phosphatase enzyme
which converts glucose 6-phosphate into
glucose is actually
not functional due to some kind of
mutations which is inherited in this
case the baby
shows symptom as early as the age of
three to four so in during infancy the
symptoms are pretty visible and the
organs that are affected are liver
kidney and muscles
sometimes intestines are also
affected
affected infants very often show very
low blood sugar levels and sometimes
that lead to seizures so overall these
kind of babies show enlargement of the
liver known as hepatomegaly enlargement
of the kidney known as
nephromegaly elevated levels of lactate
and uric acid in the blood
it can lead to uracimia and also it
shows elevated level of lipids and
triglycerides in the body
now let's talk about the cori's disease
which is another type of
glycogen storage disorder known as gsd3
now in cory's disease
it is kind of like an inherited disorder
where there is a buildup of abnormal
glycogen in the body
the accumulated glycogen is structurally
abnormal and overall it impairs the
function of the liver and muscles and
liver and the muscles are the obvious
organs which are affected symptoms
include low blood sugar excess amount of
fat in the blood elevated blood levels
of liver enzymes
sometimes muscle weakness and hypertone
hypotonia
now cory's disease is
caused due to a problem in the deep
branching enzyme deep branching enzyme
chops off the branch point of glycogens
so when there is a alpha one six
glycosidic linkage it is taken care of
by the d de-branching enzyme
in absence of de-branching enzyme there
is a faulty branching in the glycogen
which leads to abnormal glycogen
formation
so the first sign of these kind of
disease is basically very poor muscle
tone or hypotonia eventually there could
be problems in cardiac muscle as well so
there could be cardiomyopathy
now glycogen phosphorylase enzyme
generally chops off all the linear
branches of the glycogen and releases
glucose one phosphate
so in mcardle disease and hearth's
disease this particular enzyme glycogen
phosphorylase is affected
so in macaroni disease muscle is
affected the most and in
hers disease the liver or the
hepatocytes are affected
in hers disease the science and symptom
begins from the infancy to early
childhood so there is hepatomegaly there
is increase in ketone bodies and
low blood sugar and there is also
increase in fat levels
there is also a slower growth rate mild
delay in motor coordination
the baby learn several motor skills like
dancing sitting walking etc in a lower
pace so there is overall problems
now in this video what we have learned
if we just summarize that we learned
glycogen storage disorder occurs due to
the problem in glycogen metabolism and
glycogen breakdown especially
and several enzymes involved in this
pathway can be affected and they are
classified into different different
subcategories and they have different
symptoms though these symptoms varies
from one to another but there is a
overarching similarity between all of
these symptoms that is hepatomegaly and
there is myopathy that means the muscles
and the livers
are the most affected organs because
they are actively taking part in
glycogen breakdown or glycogen
metabolism
overall we see that
all of these
diseases are actually occurring from
early in the infancy
so i hope this was informative and it
was a nice summary
if you get if you want to get more notes
and flash cards you can follow me on
facebook page you can also follow my
instagram channel links are provided in
the description in my instagram page
there are mcq question solving on a
daily basis you can follow that
participate in context and can win
exciting prizes right now in my second
channel which is let's crack bio exam
there is a contest
and the prize of this contest is
displayed here this is a customized
coffee mug you just need to answer the
mcq questions in a daily basis put your
answer in the comment and like and share
these post with friends and thereby you
can win this surprise gift
anyway you can support my channel via
patreon or vmupi or also you can pay via
the super thanks option which is present
in the bottom right corner of each video
you can contribute using paytm paypal
upi or internet banking your small
contribution means a lot to me anyway
see you in the next video in case you
want to get connected with us
and you want to like uh talk to us in
social media all the links are provided
in the description go check them out and
don't forget to comment in the end of
this video do let us know how you like
our video and see you in next video